how do we see anything we don't actually
have an analogue of Superman's x-ray
vision Superman presumably emits x-rays
from his eyes then pass through an
object bounce off on something and then
they're detected back by Superman but we
see things when an external light saw
source the light bounces off the object
and then the reflected light strikes our
eye if the light is not reflected from
the object but instead bends around the
object then as far as our eyes are
concerned it's as if the object isn't
there because the only way we know about
the presence of the object is that is
when it reflects light and we can see
that light by our eyes so metamaterials
had something called what's called a
negative index of refraction so the
index of refraction normally is a
positive quantity and is responsible for
like the Mirage effect that you see when
you're putting a pencil in a glass of
water and look at the interface between
air and water the pencil will appear
broken and that's because the light
travels faster in air than it does in
water and so the difference in the speed
of light in water creates a bending of
the light rays and so our eye processes
that as the pencil appears to be broken
because of the difference in the speeds
of the of light in the different medium
a negative index refraction would bend
the pencil all the way backwards and
still be broken and for an object that
was coated in a material that had a
negative index of refraction these meta
materials the light would Bend around it
but not strike it and bounce towards our
eyes so the material would appear to be
invisible from our point of view this
been progress made if you use microwaves
or in some cases even visible light but
it has to be of only one particular
wavelength whereas the white light we
see
as a multitude of wavelengths so we're a
long way away from getting materials
that could produce invisibility cloaks
however the science is sound and it has
been experimentally confirmed and so who
I'm not going to bet against the
cleverness of scientists and engineers
coming up in the future